[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
en Estados Unidos cada vez se acerca más
el regreso de los seres humanos a la
luna como paso previo a explorar Marte
un planeta en el que se espera poder
construir una base permanente pese a la
cantidad de información que se tiene de
marte hay algo sobre lo que faltan
conocimientos y es Qué consecuencias
tendría para un humano estar un periodo
prolongado en el planeta rojo por eso la
NASA presentó su hábitat simulado de
marte donde cuatro personas estarán
Durante un año
parte de las actividades de la misión en
Marte además de la geología y la
exploración es construir y mantener una
infraestructura para seres vivos para
humanos en Marte Así que para los
humanos que vayan en próximas misiones
queremos empezar a construir nuestra
infraestructura
esta misión fue desarrollada como una
simulación de un año sobre la superficie
marciana con el objetivo de que la
tripulación viva el aislamiento y
confinamiento con restricciones
realistas de marte podemos realmente
empezar a entender cómo esas
restricciones se asocian con su salud y
rendimiento en ese periodo
el hábitat llamado Mars John Alfa está
ubicado en el centro espacial Johnson en
la ciudad de Houston el lugar está
equipado con una casa de cuatro
dormitorios que serán ocupados desde
junio una zona de cultivo vertical una
sala de Procedimientos médicos un área
de relajación un gimnasio y estaciones
de trabajo la NASA Busca medir el
desempeño y habilidades cognitivas de
quienes la habiten para entender Cuáles
son los recursos indispensables que
deben proporcionarse para el viaje
Además del aislamiento del confinamiento
y la distancia analizamos cosas como
poder llevarse bien cuando estás en un
pequeño hábitat con ya sabes otras tres
personas esto puedes gastarse con el
tiempo
esperamos Que tengan que ejercitarse un
poco para mantener su nivel de desempeño
tenemos una habitación equipada para
ello
hay un artefacto robótico que
básicamente hará las mediciones de
cognición
pasamos ahora a América Latina y vamos a
Uruguay para conocer una tecnología que
busca predecir riesgos microbiológicos y
con ello reducir las pérdidas en el
sector
agroalimentario es una creación de la
empresa metabix biotech que desarrolla
un software basado en Inteligencia
artificial y mediciones de campo el
programa Integra la información de virus
y patógenos presentes en el ambiente y
con algoritmos calcula el nivel de
riesgo esto permite que los productores
conozcan los riesgos presentes en el
ambiente antes de que se desencadene una
infección o enfermedad en animales la
misma compañía diseñó durante la
pandemia de Kobe 19 el dispositivo
cactus y de esto se trata
diseñamos esta herramienta para detectar
sars-cov 2 se viene utilizando en el
mercado para eso Pero además siempre lo
ideamos y lo pensamos como una
herramienta fundamental para la cría
intensiva de animales en confinamiento
de cultivos en condiciones controladas
para poder monitorear muestrear tomar
muestras de aire y luego detectar que
microorganismo que patógenos están
presentes en esos procesos según los
responsables con este software los
productores podrían tener una ventaja de
unos 20 días Respecto a los métodos
tradicionales para detectar los
patógenos lo que permite actuar más
rápido y minimizar pérdidas hemos
desarrollado y estamos validando
algoritmos que permiten entender y
predecir cómo se van a comportar estos
patógenos porque estamos teniendo
información poblacional de estos
ambientes Entonces estamos en una etapa
de validación para predecir cómo va a
ser el futuro comportamiento de y Qué
probabilidad hay de Que aparezca un
brote en el futuro entre los patógenos
detectables están la listeria la
salmonela la peste porcina africana el
mico plasma el adenovirus y la
bronquitis logrando identificar incluso
a nivel de variantes para los sectores
Avícola y Porcino tenemos enfermedades
como puede ser la influenza aviar o
alguna otra que son exóticas que cuando
aparecen causan un daño aberrante en un
muy corto periodo de tiempo entonces
podemos con este sistema monitorear con
diferentes estrategias los dos tipos de
problemas los del día a día digamos y
estos que aparecen por suerte una vez
cada tanto pero que cuando aparece si
tienen un impacto enorme
y vamos a finalizar en Kuwait donde el
medio cubait news presentó a la primera
conductora de noticias creada por
Inteligencia artificial se llama feda y
hace parte de un proyecto que aún está
en etapa de pruebas en un futuro la
presentadora podría adoptar el acento
Cuba Haití y conducir al informativo de
la cuenta de Twitter del medio que
cuenta con más de un millón de
Seguidores así llegamos al final de este
espacio a ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía quédense con nosotros que hay
más en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]